The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free to make a
donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT
courses, visit MIT
OpenCourseWare at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on non-linear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In the previous lectures, we
have considered quite a bit of
theory related to non-linear
finite element analysis in
some example solutions.
The objective in the next two
lectures now, the last
lectures of this video course,
is to show how an actual
finite element analysis is
performed on the computer.
We start with a linear solution
in this lecture, and
then consider a non-linear
solution in the next lecture.
We cannot discuss really, in
this amount of time given, all
the aspects of the analysis,
but want to summarize and
demonstrate on the computer
the major steps of the
analysis and concentrate on
possible difficulties,
possible pitfalls, and some
general recommendations.
As the example problem, we want
to use the plate with a
hole, that we already
considered earlier.
And we performed a linear
analysis and then
a non-linear analysis.
Remember, I pointed out in the
previous lectures that it is
very important to always do
linear analysis first before
you go into a non-linear
analysis.
The elastic analysis is
performed to obtain the stress
concentration factor at the
hole, then we do an
elasto-plastic analysis to
estimate the limit load, and
an analysis also to investigate
the effect of a
shaft in the plate hole.
These two analyses are being
performed in the last lecture
of the video course.
The plate we are analyzing is
shown on this view graph here.
Notice it's a square plate.
Here, we show the hole, the
plate is loaded as shown up
here, and down here.
The material property for the
elastic analysis are given
here and the thickness of
the plate is 0.01 meter.
Because of symmetry conditions,
we only need to
consider this quarter here.
Of course, using appropriate
boundary conditions along
these two lines. we will talk
about that more later on.
The first step for a finite
element analysis is to select
a computer program, and we, of
course, use the ADINA system.
ADINA-IN is the pre-processor
to prepare, generate the
finite element data.
ADINA then solves the actual
finite element model, and
ADINA-PLOT is used to this
display numerically or
graphically the solution
results.
Schematically, we are sitting
here at a terminal and we're
inputting the data
to ADINA-IN.
We can also receive here,
numerical output, and we can
also plot on this terminal here,
any of the information
that we like to plot.
This is a graphics terminal.
Notice ADINA-IN, of course,
communicates to a storage
device and further on
to ADINA, as we will
discuss just now.
The user inputs, in
other words, or
types into the terminal.
ADINA-IN commands interactively
or for batch
processing and then the user
checks also the input and the
generated data on the graphics
device, as I showed you on the
previous view graph.
ADINA-IN generates the
input data for ADINA.
The input data is checked
internally in ADINA in for
errors and inconsistency, and
also is displayed as you are
requesting it as a user.
The degree of freedom numbers
are generated and to obtain
minimum bandwidth, we have a
minimum bandwidth minimization
algorithm in the program, as
I will point out a bit
stronger later on.
ADINA data inputs then, is
available to ADINA, and the
user runs ADINA, and ADINA then
stores the output data on
a porthole file and
on an output file.
The output file, in other words,
contains really the
ADINA model data and the
calculated results.
We access ADINA porthole
file using ADINA-PLOT.
We can, of course, also look
at the output file and see
numerically the data that was
calculated using ADINA.
Here, we have the action
displayed or schematically
shown by the user.
User uses ADINA-PLOT to fetch
data from the ADINA porthole
file and then ADINA-PLOT
displays those data either
numerically or graphically.
Let's look very briefly at
an overview of ADINA.
The program can be used for
static and dynamic solutions,
for linear and non-linear
analysis, for small and very
large finite element models,
and the formulations finite
elements and numerical
procedures used in the program
have largely been discussed
in this course.
The displacement assumptions
that can be employed for the
finite element models are either
infinitesimally small
displacements, large
displacements, large rotations
but small strains, and large
deformations, large strains.
We discussed these assumptions,
of course, also
in the course.
Material models that are
available in isotropic linear
elastic model, orthotropic
linear elastic model,
isotropic thermo-elastic model,
a curve description
model for analysis of geological
materials, a
concrete model, isothermal
plasticity models,
thermo-elastic-plastic and creep
models, and non-linear
elastic incompressible, and
user-supplied models.
The elements available in the
program, is available number
nodes tress element, an element
that can have two
nodes, three nodes,
or four nodes.
It can also be used
as a ring element.
A two-dimensional solid element
that is used for plane
stress axis symmetric and
plane strain analysis.
This also can have available
number of nodes, from four
nodes to nine nodes.
Similarly, available number
of nodes element for
three-dimensional analysis.
Then also a beam element, a
2-node beam element, Hermitian
beam element.
And the isoparametric beam
element that we talked about
in the course.
This element can carry, or can
be used with two nodes, or
three nodes, or four nodes.
A pipe element that we did not
discuss in the course, but you
might be interested in reading
about that element is a curved
beam element, of course,
of pipe section.
Which however, also includes the
effects of ovalization So
this element also carries, if
desired ovalization degrees of
freedoms at the nodes.
And shell elements, we talked
about the use of the 16-node
element, and the MITC 4,
the 4-node element.
We also talked briefly about
transition elements that I
used to model shells,
or thin structures
that couple into solids.
Let us summarize some important
observations
regarding finite element
analysis.
It's important to check the
finite element data, of
course, very carefully.
The data must be checked
prior to the
actual response solution.
This is done, of course, with
the pre-processor, by plotting
the data, looking at it very
carefully, typically.
And then after the response
solution, you still want to
check the input data once more
by seeing whether the boundary
conditions are properly
satisfied, that you want to
impose on to the model, whether
the displacement and
stress solution is
a reasonable.
Once the analysis has been
performed, you want to very
carefully evaluate
and interpret
the calculate response.
You want to start in detail the
calculated displacement
and stresses along
certain lines.
In particular, look
at stress jumps.
We pointed that out already in
an earlier lecture, and we
will do so in our example
solution again, just now.
And here, I'd like to add that
stress averaging, stress
smoothing should only be done
after the above careful
evaluation.
That's something important
to keep in mind.
I believe that you should first
look at the stresses,
the way they have been
calculated by the program and
then start thinking about
stress smoothing.
Only after you've gone through
this phase here.
The data for the construction
of the finite element mesh,
that we want to deal with in the
example solution is input
for this quarter of
the plate, as I
pointed out earlier already.
We have these elastic material
constants, we're looking at a
plane stress analysis.
This is the thickness
of the plate.
And once again, here
is a loading.
Notice, we are putting this
boundary on rollers, and we
want to put this boundary as
well on rollers to model the
symmetry conditions that we
need to model in order to
consider a whole plate, where we
actually analyze here, only
one quarter of that plate.
The finite element mesh that we
will be using is shown on
this view graph.
It consists of 64 8-node
isoparametric elements.
Well, we performed this analysis
on the computer in my
laboratory at MIT a few weeks
ago, and we have brought in a
video crew to record all the
actions that we have been
performing to actually complete
the analysis.
I like to now share with you
what we have recorded and
narrate to you as we go step by
step through the analysis
of this plate on the computer.
Our first step is to look at
how we are generating using
ADINA-IN, how we are generating
this mesh, and also
the other data that are required
for use of ADINA.
So let's look at this first step
now, after which I will
then introduce you to the next
step and narrate continuous
narration of the analysis.
Here we show briefly the
hardware equipment we are
using in my MIT laboratory.
A MASSCOMP minicomputer with two
megabytes of real memory,
and 330 megabytes
of disk storage.
We also have a tape drive.
The computer features virtual
memory, and we use a
Unix-based operating system.
Roughly, for our purposes,
the computer is
equivalent to a VAX 750.
We use two terminals.
One terminal for alphanumerical
and numerical
input and output, and one
terminal, the one to the
right, for graphical output.
We also have a plotter.
We use this plotter to generate
the figures of finite
element meshes, and results
for this course.
Here comes my student,
Ted [? Sossman, ?]
who will sit at the
terminal to input
the data to the program.
In what follows, we will see the
data input prepared by Ted
on the terminal at
which he sits.
Non-graphical output is
displayed by that same
terminal, whereas we will see
graphical output displayed on
the right terminal.
Here, we see the start of input
preparation for ADINA-IN.
We have opened the data base,
on which the data input and
generated will be stored and
have already input the title
for the analysis, quarter plate
with hole, 64 elements.
We have also defined master
degrees of freedom conditions
by specifying the
values of IDOF.
1 means of a deleted degree of
freedom, 0 means a free,
existing degree of freedom.
Here, all degrees of freedom
have been deleted except for
the yz displacements.
Notice also that at
our request, all
text appears twice.
After we have typed a line, the
line is echoed back by the
program merely for checking.
In what follows, we now specify
the coordinates of a
few key points that defines
the outline of the
quarter of the plate.
Note we define the y-
and z-coordinates.
First of node 1, then for
nodes 2, 3, 4, 5, and 6.
Note that these coordinates
are input in free format.
Here the node 6 input is not
aligned with the other nodal
point coordinate input.
We now want to look at the plot
of these nodal points.
This is achieved by the frame
and mesh commands.
Here they are, the six points.
Point 1 is the center of the
hole, points 2 and 3 defines
the boundary of the hole.
Points 4, 5, 6 defines the
remaining corners of the
quarter plate.
And here, you see the first
set of generated nodes.
Note that the nodal points have
consecutive numbers along
the vertical symmetry edge,
except for the top and bottom
nodes, numbers 3 and 4,
similarly for the horizontal
symmetry edge.
This would mean a large
bandwidth unless we use a
bandwidth minimizer.
And we will do so, hence we
are not concerned with the
nodal point numbering
used at this stage.
Next, we generate also the nodal
points on the remaining
edges of the quarter plate.
And here they are.
We now want to generate the
elements of the plate.
For this we define, first the
material to be a elastic.
Young's modulus E, Poisson's
ratio NU.
We want a plane stress
element group.
The Gauss integration
order is 3x3.
The material set has a number 1,
this is the material set we
just defined.
The G-surface command next
generates the 8-node elements
in the domain defined by the
corner points, so to
say 6, 4, 3, 2.
We now want to plot the
generated element mesh, and
here, you see it.
Note once again, we use 8-note
isoparametric elements, around
the hole, they are
curved elements.
Finally, we also define in the
ADINA-IN input the elements
thicknesses to be 0.01 and the
loads which correspond to the
pulling on the plate.
This [? end ?] completes
the input preparation
for ADINA-IN .
ADINA-IN has now all the
information to generate a
complete input file ADINA.
In addition, we also want to
ask ADINA-IN to assign
equation numbers that correspond
to a minimum
bandwidth for the solution
of this problem.
So our next step is to have
ADINA-IN go through these
actions, and turn back to our
laboratory and see what is
happening now.
Here, we see the end of the
ADINA-IN input file that we
saw already before.
The command ADINA now generates
the ADINA file.
At the same, also, the bandwidth
of the stiffness
matrix is minimized.
We use the reverse Cuthill-Mckee
algorithm.
Notice that the bandwidth has
been reduced from 399 to 93.
The original bandwidth was, of
course, artificially large
because our nodal point
generation did not take
account of any bandwidth
considerations, as I pointed
out before.
Let us briefly look
at the ADINA file
generated by the ADINA-IN.
Here, we see common cards,
automatically inserted by
ADINA-IN to explain
the input cards.
We see the master control card,
the load control card,
the Eigenvalue solution control
card, and so on.
Let us look a bit closer at
the element data cards.
Element 1 has eight nodes and
the first three are 6, 64, 74.
Element 2 has 8 nodes and the
first three are 64, 62, 76.
Note a maximum of nine
nodes is possible.
The last 0 is the node card
signifies that the ninth node
is not used.
With a complete ADINA input
file now available, we can
call ADINA to execute this file
and this gives us our
first solution results.
We look at the solution results
and, in particular, we
plot the deformed mesh onto the
original mesh, and this
shows, in fact, that we have
made an error in the input
description.
It will show us that we have
fixed all these nodes down
here, whereas they should
have been on a roller.
This is shown by plotting the
deformed mesh on to the
original mesh, and it's
also shown by
looking at the stresses.
We do so by using an option in
the ADINA system for the
stress vector outputs, and this
is schematically shown
here, this option.
We plot maximum principle
stresses--
say tensile in this
case here--
as a line with two arrows, and
principles stress that's
compressive as simply a line.
So we can see, in other words,
how the stress flows through
the material, and we can see,
of course, compressive and
tensile stress situations, and
notice that the lengths of
these lines corresponds or is
proportional to the magnitude
of the stresses.
We can plot this stress vector
output for all the integration
points stresses in the mesh, and
that, as I said already,
indicates clearly once again,
that we have used the wrong
boundary conditions down here.
So we go and correct the
boundary conditions down here,
and re-run the analysis.
In other words, call ADINA again
and those results that
we obtained then, once again,
displacements, in other words,
are plotted by plotting the
deformed mesh onto the
original mesh.
We see that we now got much
better, much more
realistically-looking results.
And we also will look at the
stresses using the stress
vector plots again, in the
elements, that show us also
that the results are now quite
realistic and that our mesh,
including the boundary
conditions have been quite
properly defined.
So let us now look at this
step of the analysis.
The command runadina
calls ADINA to
execute the input data.
The data input file is
in ADINA-IN F02.
And here, we see now the
deformed plotted onto the
original mesh.
The original mesh is plotted
in dash lines.
Of course, the deformations
are magnified.
Note that as expected, the top
face has uniformly moved up.
However, note that the nodal
points on the horizontal
symmetry line have not
displaced at all.
This is quite unphysical and
shows that the wrong boundary
conditions have been used.
If we look at the stress vector
plot over the mesh, the
same conclusion is reached.
For clarity, on the video, we
show here the stress vectors
just on the elements closest
to the hole.
And we can see in the element
adjoining the horizontal
symmetry line, a stress that
acts normal to the whole.
This is, of course,
unphysical.
Next, we show the stress vectors
in the outer most
elements of the quarter plate.
And you can see here, a stress
acting perpendicular to the
free edge of the plate, when
we look near the horizontal
symmetry line.
This is also unphysical and is
due to having specified the
wrong boundary conditions
on the wrong
horizontal symmetry line.
The specification
of the boundary
conditions is shown here.
The character, C, denotes the
boundary condition on the
horizontal symmetry line.
The character B denotes the
boundary condition on the
vertical symmetry line.
Where B means only the z
displacement is free and C
means all displacements
are fixed.
For the six possible
displacements and
[? flotatations, ?]
a 1 means the degree of freedom
is fixed, and 0 means
the degree of freedom is free.
We now correct the boundary
conditions.
And B on the horizontal symmetry
line means now the v
displacement is free.
C on the vertical symmetry
line means now the w
displacement is free.
We run ADINA again, and here
you see the deformed mesh
plotted on the original mesh.
The deformations look
very reasonable.
The plate has contracted
horizontally, and
correspondingly, the hole
has shrunk horizontally.
The deformations closest to
the hole are shown here.
And here, we see the
stress vector
plots for these elements.
The stresses align nicely
with the hole.
Notice that there is no stress
perpendicular to the free
surface of the hole when we look
at the integration point
layer closest as a hole.
The value of the maximum
stress is given here.
It is 301.9 megapascal.
Here, we look at the element
which carries the largest
stress, element 57.
Once again, we can see that
the stresses align
nicely with the hole.
We now recall is that the
objective of our analysis is
really the calculation of the
stress concentration factor.
And if we look at the problem
once more, here, we have the
plate with the hole.
The plate subjected to the
tractions, as shown here.
We now need to, of course,
predict the stresses
accurately around the hole,
and in particular, at this
point here.
Here, we have our
finite element
method used in the analysis.
And so far, the only calculated
stresses at the
integration points
in the elements.
Now this is here, by the
way, element number 57.
And for this element, we have
calculated so far, only the
stresses at these integration
points.
However, these integration
points do not lie on the
circumference of the hole, on
the boundary of the hole.
And that is where the maximum
stresses occur.
Of particular interest is, of
course, also this point here,
where we anticipate to
obtain the maximum
stress in the analysis.
If you look at, schematically,
how the stresses would vary,
say, through the element, to the
boundary of the hole, we
would see a schematic
plot as shown here.
Here is an actual element, the
other elements lie next to it,
and here you can see
schematically shown the stress
computed at the closest
integration point to the
boundary of the hole.
And here, we would have
the stress computed
at the nodal point.
That is actually the stress
that we are interested in.
Well, we can ask ADINA to
calculate the stresses at the
nodal points, and then we can
ask ADINA-PLOT to enter with
these nodal point stresses
into this formula here.
Sigma yy, sigma zz, and sigma
yz are the stresses at the
nodal points.
To calculate, ADINA-PLOT
calculate this Sigma 1, which
is the maximum principle of
stress at that nodal point.
We can ask ADINA-PLOT to
calculate sigma 1 at all the
nodal points in the mesh, and by
doing so, we obtained these
stresses and then they can ask
ADINA-PLOT to search through
those nodal points stresses,
these sigma 1 stresses, to
find us the location, the
element and the nodal point,
to have the physical location
of the maximum stress
occurring in the mesh.
We will see that doing so,
ADINA-PLOT comes up to tell us
that this is the point, element
number 57, point
number 4, that is this physical
point here, where the
maximum stress occurs and will
also give us that maximum
stress, and that maximum stress,
of course, gives us
then the stress concentration
factor.
So let us now look at this
phase of the analysis.
Here, we have input some
information regarding
variables that need be defined
in ADINA plot.
TYY refers to tau yy, TZZ
refers to tau zz, TYZ
refers to tau yz.
We define the result and
variable to calculate the
maximum principle stress.
Hence, when TYY, TZZ, and TYZ
are defined [? smax ?]
gives the maximum principle
stress.
Here, we now enter the command
to look for the maximum
principal stress in the mesh.
First we make a small input
error, obtain a message, we
correct the input, and here
comes the result.
We see that indeed element
57.4 carries a maximum
principle stress and this value
is 345.151 megapascal.
We have now actually obtained
an answer to the
question that we asked.
Originally, namely, we wanted
to calculated the stress
concentration factor
around the hole.
And we have obtained a number
for that stress
concentration factor.
However, a valid question,
certainly is to ask, how good
is this number?
After all, we used a finite
element mesh to approximate
the plate a particular finite
element idealization was used,
and we have only obtained
an approximation
to the exact result.
Well, to evaluate that question,
to obtain insight
into that question, to evaluate
how good our analysis
results really are, we can plot
stress jumps, the way we
discussed it in an
earlier lecture.
And in particular, for the
analysis that I'd like to show
you in this final phase, we
have plotted stress jumps
along these two lines.
Now, notice that, for example,
at this node here, we have
four elements coupling into this
node, so at this node we
get four different stress
predictions
for each stress component.
At this node here, we would
have only two stress
predictions, for each stress
component because only two
elements couple into
this node.
That is one way to evaluate or
to look at how accurate our
results are.
An alternative way is to plot
pressure bands, and the
pressure here is scalar.
It's computed as shown here,
and we can plot bands of
constant pressure, the way we
already have discussed it in
an earlier lecture.
Notice because this is a scalar,
it can be used very
nicely to plot these bands
of constant pressure.
Of course, we could also have
used here, say, an effective
stress, which is also a scalar,
and we could plot
bands of constant effective
stresses.
One example that you've seen
already early, is this one
here where we plotted pressure
bands, with band magnitude of
5 MPa, megapascal, and you can
see here this white band, here
a black band, in other words,
we're going in steps 5 MPa
from one band to the next.
Notice that there's a pressure
band discontinuity right here,
which already indicates that we
have a stress discontinuity
here, and which indicates that
the mesh that we used is
really not a very fine mesh.
And if we are interested in
obtaining a very accurate
result, then based on these
pressure band plots, and also
the stress jump plots that I
will show you just now, we may
actually decide to
use a finer mesh.
We discussed this issue already
in an earlier lecture.
So let us now then look at what
happens, or what happened
in this final phase
of the analysis.
Let's go back to the laboratory
and share the
experiences that we'll
see there.
Here, we see once more
the mesh we're
using in the analysis.
We will plot the stresses, and
hence, we can see the stress
jumps along the horizontal
symmetry line, and the
diagonal line of the plate.
Here, you see the stresses along
the horizontal symmetry
line, Tau zz is plotted.
The horizontal axis measures
distance along
the symmetry line.
And the vertical axis measures
the stress values.
Note that the stress predictions
at the nodes, when
calculated for the different
elements are almost the same.
Only at one node can we actually
see a difference, and
it is quite small.
Note that two elements couple
into this node.
Hence, there are only small
stress jumps along the
horizontal symmetry
axis of the plate.
Next, we look at the stress plot
along the diagonal line
of the model.
Here the maximum principle
stress is plotted.
Note that at one node into which
four elements couple, we
have four markedly different
stress values.
Indeed, we have significant
stress jumps at that node, but
otherwise the stress
predictions do
not show large jumps.
Finally, we look at the
pressure band plots.
Here, they are drawn.
To save time, we skipped some
of the drawing process and
jumped to a later
picture here.
We notice that the pressure
bands are quite continuous,
except between the first and
second layer of elements
around the hole.
This corresponds to the stress
discontinuity between these
element layers that
we saw earlier.
We see now this is now
completed, I'd like to look
with you once more back on to
two view graphs that we
already have looked
at earlier.
On this you graph, we summarize
some important
observations.
And we said that it is very
important to check the finite
element data input carefully
prior to the actual response
solution run.
That, of course, means
plotting the data.
And we have done so, of course,
in our analysis.
And after the response solution
has been obtained, by
starting whether desired
boundary conditions are
satisfied, whether displacement
and stress
solution is reasonable.
Remember, in our analysis, we
did this, of course, as well
and we found, by looking at the
boundary conditions, the
way they were represented in the
actual solution, that we
have actually made an error.
In other words, we looked at
the deformed mesh, and the
boundary conditions on the
deformed mesh in our first
analysis showed that we had
fixed the boundary at the
bottom off the mesh,
which was an error.
So it is very important to go
through this step, to look
very closely whether the
boundary conditions are
actually satisfied on the mesh
that you have been using, in
the right way.
Of course, the same holds for
the stress and solution.
Remember, that we looked at the
stress plots for the mesh
that was fixed at the bottom
and we could directly see
there were errors there, and,
in other words, the error of
having fixed the boundary at
the bottom of the plate.
So this step is most important,
and we have seen an
example in the analysis that
we just completed.
I also had this view graph
already on, where we said that
we want to carefully evaluate
and interpret
the calculated response.
We want to study, in detail,
the calculated displacement
and stresses along certain
lines, study stress jumps.
Well, we saw an example of that
in the analysis that we
just completed, and we also
pointed out that it is
important to go through this
step here first, prior to
using a stress averaging because
if you do average
stresses, of course, you would
never see stress jumps.
And this can be an important
step to gain confidence in the
analysis results that
you have obtained.
This then completes what I
wanted to share with you in
this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.